pau
[Musique]
et
et vous la bande de racailles
vous êtes trop large pour m'attaquer
qu'est ce qui se passe là nous fait part
ou quoi je parie que vous êtes à 4,2 me
bouffe eldar vous êtes des couilles
molles bande de tarnos petits branleurs
[Musique]
eux ce sont les camarades de classe
on n'a pas toujours tuer des gens ça au
départ c'est la faute de séduire tout a
commencé il ya un mois à l'hôtel de
fuente 9
[Musique]
où
lui c'est pablo domingo le prof de
littérature et la nana avec la gueule de
mouches mortes
c'est sylvia s'est dit qu'est ce que tu
fais là je vous êtes en fait moi le
plaisir de ficher le camp
je sais comme attendiez vous voulez
vraiment que je parte
tu n'aurais pas dû venir ici c'est
inutile de faire comme si vous savez
très bien ce qu'il est entré nous
écoutent sylviane je ne sais pas quel
film tu te fais mais dans la vraie vie
les professeurs n'ont pas de liaison
avec leurs élèves
je sais que te plaît tu adores me
regarder la façon dont tu me regardes en
classe
je sais que tu amoureux de moi
je vais te donner ce que tu veux on a le
temps de le faire avant que magdalena
arrive
magdalena j'ignore comment tu as fait
pour être au courant mais t'inquiète pas
petit gars du temps nous en avant
je crois que c'était moi vous attendiez
toi non mais j'adore les surprises
[Musique]
tu vas bien ici
ont dû faire laissez moi sortir tu n'es
pas venu pour ça
je vais crier tant mieux ça m'excite
[Musique]
qui sait ce qui est dit la petite gare
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suite à mon dieu comme seigneur lacoste
aliot cette fille super canon c'est non
rien oui c'est bien
ça c'est le pauvre mec de la classe
c'est à dire moi
[Musique]
bonjour ni sipa pour 2011
et c'est votre message au public algérie
c'est à magda j'espère que tu as pu te
libérer des tâches use de femme pensant
je viens de crever un pneu
je le change et ensuite j'arrive
takako
c'est magdalena la prof vite ne m'a pas
dit ce qui se passe est si j'étais petit
falcon a t'il via les affaires quoi tu
verras toi qu'est-ce que magdalena avoir
la foi
tu ne dis jamais rien si tu veux qu'on
soit administré tant que team est ravie
je t'en prie conduite et toi c'est pas
si dur
puisque tu es si futé et vas-y tout seul
ravir violent ravine ne laisse pas
tomber
ravie je te promets tout ce que tu veux
mais ce que je voudrais oui ce que tu
voudras mais à deux mois écoute il ya
trois jours tu m'as dit en avait rien à
[ __ ] de moi mais ensuite quand un des
problèmes est que les pâtes ont pas de
pièce là tu viens me trouver j'aimerais
savoir à quoi tu joues
parce que je suis humain comme toi
peut-être plus que sérieux sérieux bon
bah j'espère que cette fois c'est vrai
parce que je supporte plus cette
situation
oui il faut qu'on arrive à vendre
magdane et dale pourquoi [ __ ] c'est
reparti
[Musique]
elle est derrière faut pas renoncer à
les appeler fort tu crois que ça court
ça
[Musique]
où est il ravit promets moi que quoi
qu'il arrive tu avec nous ravit promène
moi je te le promets
oh [ __ ] je sais pas quoi faire c'est
arrivé comment je sais pas comment ça tu
sais pas via le canal du prof de lettres
dans sa baignoire et tu sais pas ce qui
s'est passé c'est bon on arrête tes
gosses qu'on va faire maintenant j'en
sais rien ravi mais faut se dépêcher
parce que magdalena va arriver il faut
déjà sortir cet abruti de la baignoire
aidez moi [ __ ]
[Musique]
hollande
donc tu es allé là-bas en pensant qu'il
voulait coucher avec toi
et là tu as réalisé qu'en fait c'était
magdalena qu'ils attendaient ça
malgré ça il t'a fait des avances à toi
et tu les as sommer je pouvais pas juste
lui dire non et puis c'est tout il l a
violée
tu voulais qu'elle fasse sa conversation
portable
c'est pas le mien et ligne c'est pas
grave il va s'arrêter faut penser à
comment se débarrasser du corps à corps
comment rebondir
ils vont nous mettre très tranquille à
cause de moi comme mes parents à savoir
imam tué quelqu'un a une idée
oui on abandonne la voiture avec le
cadavre de dents sur le bord de la route
et on dirait la police coûte la volée
ouais pourquoi on n'abandonne pas la
case était plutôt parents ravis
bon désolé s'il vient si on fait ça nous
chanterons
il faut laisser le corps quelque part
c'était juste une idée
on est bien parti
[Applaudissements]
bonjour ici pablo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais voilà ils vont le retrouver
non c'est une vieille mine abandonnée
ça fait plus de 20 ans que personne n'y
viens ici est ce qu'on le trouve
il peut encore se passer 15 ans et avec
un peu de chance les vautours
s'occuperont de lui dommage dp fille
c'était un [ __ ] il trompe sa femme
deux fois et en plus c'est les sept
violée ouais mais ils étaient mignons
venez je vous invite à boire une bière
tu gardes ton portable ouais sa valise
elle est tout neuf
[Musique]
on part jamais à personne monde tu l'as
déjà entonné faire des tours j'ai
entendu dire oui à quelque chose que lui
a demandé au préfet matt hill par notre
longuement avec les noms qu'il a je
pense que je peux rien je raccompagne
non merci à vie je vais rentrer en bus
pour rentrer en voiture à notre jeu ça
les filles vous étiez ou pas se promener
à tresser dit toujours que chaque jour
tant velits c'est pas possible tu rêves
mario plutôt mourir tu te sortir avec
toi harry qui rentre chez toi je te
raconte âge je comprends misshitsu
oublier la cette conne la seule chose
qu'il a branché les pc belge et les
ringards communes tulle en revendre la
beuh pourtant ouais mais les affaires
sont les affaires et c'est pas parce que
tu a redoublé qu'il faut laisser marcher
sur les pieds
faut que tu sois fier de sa horde oublie
c'est une des meilleures choses qui soit
au monde à part baiser britney spears je
croyais que tu l'aimés pas sa musique
non mais j'ai a pas couché dans la
baignoire qui était dans mon pull faut
pas que sa chérie à laymont
et la tranche de cake
où il a fait une mauvaise chute
ici les ouistitis mêlée bien rasé lui la
jolie blouse qu'il échoue boulot les
petites oreilles auquel acheter un nom
de zot
[Rires]
ouais bonjour je cherche sylvia
maj entrés par la porte
merci
[Musique]
salut si le dire tu fais quoi durée par
ton vélo ou aussi je faisais du vélo tu
sais quand j'étais jeune et innocente
comme toi pourquoi vous est devenu ce
week-end j'avais rendez vous avec pablo
domingo temps professeur au relais de
foin d'aînés et comme c'est étrange il a
réservé mais il n'est pas venu au début
je me suis dit qu il avait eu des
remords et qu'il était resté à la maison
avec sa femme
après tout ce sont des choses qui
peuvent arriver mais jette un petit coup
d'oeil sur ce que j'ai retrouvé par
terre dans la chambre c'est pas moi je
me le suis demandé de quelle sylvia
s'agit-il puis je me suis souvenu que
pablo m'avait dit que tu me persécutait
s'est redit qu une fillette comme toi
tombée amoureuse d'un homme dans la
force de l'âge
en plus la date de naissance coïncide
avec la tienne je les vérifier dans la
fiche des élèves du lycée
je ne sais rien ecoute-moi la papillote
j'ai pour ce qui s'est passé mais tu est
appliquée jusqu'au qui n'ait voulu
retourner à sainte brigitte de peindre
je m'en fiche mais il faut que je me
parle j'ai rien à vous dire si tu refuse
de parler
j'irai tout raconté au directeur
n'oublie pas que j'ai encore ça mais je
le dirai à tes parents tu auras bien
mérité une bonne raclée il en a sa
claque de vous mais quitte à parler de
ça vous voulez savoir où il est loin de
vous ils vous détestez il ne pouvait pas
sortir
vous êtes complètement restituer
menteuse non vous savez bien que non
et en plus il m'a écrit une lettre une
marque compte ou non ce n'est pas vrai
vous voulez réagir
et là dans le tiroir
[Musique]
je ne trouve pas
s'il te plaît autant pourquoi tu dis pas
à temps c'est pas si facile si on sort
ensemble et qu'on fait rien quoi on
cesserait d'être amis et si jamais on
fait tu crois qu'il serait fâché que je
sois plus vierge à 17 ans tu voulais
dire j'attends mariage c'est fou ce
qu'ils sont machos les mecs c'est dingue
procès il est pas comme les autres c'est
un garçon qui comprend bien la mentalité
moi je crois qu'il est vraiment
différent attend à l'eau
bon tu me fais peur tu fais quoi moi
j'attends nuria et toi non je rentre et
je dois aider ma mère avec leur passage
mais si tu veux on peut se voir plus
tard ok ok bon ça ensemble ouais tu
m'envoies un message d'accord tiens
j'ai écouté ce que tu disais des belles
tu sais ce que tu dois faire baiser avec
moi comme ça au moins tu seras ce que
c'est qu'un grand brâkmar six mois la
paix elle tous les effaroucher qu'est ce
qu'il ya viens avec ma vie pour que
martel
je lui ai tout dit elle vient nous aider
au mas possède tellement dur pour toi
aller où dans le placard
comment tu as fait tes devoirs mais
qu'est-ce que [ __ ] c'est dégueu pardon
tableau quelque part ici d'un abbas il
ferme la porte
qu'est ce que ta bouffe et ça pue le sol
et est maintenant on fait quoi
la même chose qu'avec l'autre non tu
veux quoi qu'on met dans la voiture et
qu'on fasse 100 kilomètres jusqu'à la
mine ont peu l'intérêt d'un jardin ah
non pas dans mon jardin mais par vos
cuisses ils l'apprennent faut quand même
s'en débarrasser non l'enterrer c'est
une bonne idée non
mais ici non dans le parc de cas
barcella on la met dans le coffre de la
voiture et cette nuit on ira l'enterrer
là bas et les tigres et les hippopotames
ya qu une partie du parc est une réserve
le reste c'est de la forêt on va pouvoir
entrer ça c'est facile il ya une entrée
c'est là que vont les couples qui
veulent on me l'a racontée et moi me
laisse pas sortir le soir rester-là
batak à faire le mur parce que tout ça
c'est ta faute à toi fais gaffe parce
que tu dis sylvie un nom tu veux pas
pleurer
viens je te demande pardon
[Musique]
à qui
m
alors
salut kravis on y va on y va
oui martin j'en sais rien je viens juste
d'arriver je voulais tu remercieras vie
pourquoi parce que tu es là pour nous
donner un coup de main ah non tu en fais
pas tu sais bien
quant à des problèmes c'est moi que tu
appelles quand tu vas faire la fête ou
tu veux sortir avec un mec bas c'est un
autre gars que tu appelles et il ya une
voiture qui arrive
martin n'a pas de voiture
on
j'ai été obligé de tout lui raconter
mille à jurer de rien dire tu as intérêt
sinon la prochaine victime ce sera toi
c'est pas grave
rocé il faut garder ça pour toi j'ai
pigé non je te parle sérieusement parce
que nourrissent notre peau avec
serviette jus coule ça lui ravi ça va
ouais ça va j'adore ta veste
ouais je me la suis acheté l'autre jour
elle était en salle ça fait longtemps
que je cherchais une comme celle là si
j'avais su j'aurais appelé mais je sais
pas si elle est top et les mecs on peut
commencer à faire ce qu'on est venu
faire enfin c'est une idée paraison
français tu te souvenir de magdalena
ouais c'est la première fois que je vois
un macchabée impressionnant
[Musique]
allez décamper ochir allé me cacher vous
sale fils de [ __ ] une bonne guerre
ouais c'est ça c'est ça qu'il nous
faudrait un mois vous avez pourri mais
heures de sommeil patricia n'ont rien
qu'est ce que tu fais là avec mario et
vous alors et avec un cadavre
c'est alors qu'en sera contré sa demande
reste de la classe bas et nous quand on
leur dira où vous étiez si tu parles
jeter la coupe ok c'est bon je dirais
rien mais rien ok ok qui c'est bon aidez
nous à l'enterrer on vous dit ouais mais
faut faire gaffe aux gardes
il nous a surpris le garde et rennes de
l'autre côté et vient jamais ici qu'est
ce que t'en sais pas on me l'a dit faut
qu'on se grouiller l'état
[Musique]
maintenant m'attaquer ce qui se passe et
c'est qui lui dis donc t'es bizarre il
se passe quoi ça cause de ce bouffon
n'ont rien à voir mais alors c'est quoi
je peux pas te le dire mais on est amis
ou non je peux pas je t'assure j'ai
donné ma parole
bon tant pis si je te le dis tu promets
de rien dire à qui que ce soit tu peux
compter sur moi mais si maintenant que
j'ai des nouvelles fois cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui habitants font que promettre de dire
personne ce que je vais te raconter bon
mais je regarde comment et pas tout pour
moi et puis avec sa passe de mouches
mortes et comment le prochain
non mais
mais avec elle m'a dit qu'elle aille se
permettre ce type avec cette gold abruti
c'est juan perez
il a pas l'air bien malin mais pourtant
tel qu'il est là c'est quand même lui
qui allait devenir un des plus gros prix
alors alors alors écoute moi ça fait
depuis 6 heures du matin que j'essaie
d'avoir encore une nuit de fête comme
celle là et tu te retrouves son boulot
j'étais en train de dormir
non mais arrête tes conneries juanito
j'y crois pas tes salades et écoute moi
y ait du nouveau quoi la wii wii la wii
concentre toi ok on a deux disparus à
tort il avait gagné aucune piste non
j'ai un mot tu vas pas encore marc filer
une affaire pourrit en plus ma voiture
refuse de démarrer
bah tu te gouye et tu prends ce foutu
train parce que je commence à en avoir
plein les bottes de thé cimade les tu
m'as tu en profites tu m'entends j'étais
en train de navires tu passes au
commissariat je te donnerai un faux et
au fait t'as qu'à prendre le train j'en
ai ma claque de citron vert
maman gillet jeu les choses à faire ça
lui permet et si je suis pressé le peu
de filles qui viennent par ici
en quoi je peux être utile je cherche
une arme défendre pour te défendre
contre quoi
beaucoup de choses il est des gens qui
veulent faire du mal à quelqu'un comme
moi ça c'est parce que tu te réveilles
tu es comme si tu étais avec moi tu
aurais pas avoir peur de quoi que ce
soit oui pourquoi
pour ça tu as vu il perd depuis un an
comme celle là tu en verras pas souvent
fait là un shampoing se rétrécit pas au
lavage eux vous avez les âmes de poids
non on va pas ça aux moins de 18 ans bah
si vous étiez un bon gars ordinaire non
mais un mauvais garçon comme vous bien
sûr que si eh bien eh bien eh bien alors
en voyant ça ça c'est une petite
merveille sur terre
c'est un modèle super classe calibre 9
mm
ces suies que les femmes elle préfère
parce que c'est comme une [ __ ] de piques
mais pas très grosse île facile à gérer
il est pas mal mais je cherche une un
beaucoup plus puissante
les visages les guerres enfin on va voir
s'il autres gadgets que j'ai là te
laisse froide ou s'il déclenche un
incendie dans ta petite culotte
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce genre là qui te ferait plaisir
si tu la mets dans un grand sac
personnes au sort et tu là c'est celle
que j'utilise dans la boutique
mais si elle te plait je vous pourrait
en commander une autre arme en contact
vous pouvez charger bien sûr poubelle
il faut que tu fasses attention avec cet
engin là c'est une arme très puissante
mais si tu veux juste défendre avec ça
tu réussiras sûr et certain tiens le
voilà vous êtes sûr qu'il fonctionne que
je meure tout de suite si je dis des
mensonges d'accord allô allô
je t'en prie souvient me dis pas que
c'est toi c'est moi où tu es chez
l'armurier dont l'armure et attends moi
je viens
[Musique]
mais regarde pas comme ça j'ai eu peur
c'est tout allo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savard avis tu crois que c'est normal
j'ai pas envie de me taire et de crier
écoute ça m'est égal que tu es descendu
de profs je comprend des raisons et je
comprends que tu es flinguer ce nazi
c'était un connard mais ce que je pige
pas c'est ta façon de chantonnay et ses
machines elle et c'était machinal de
faire exploser la cervelle à ce type là
aussi on en a parlé à personne
c'est déjà assez qu'ils soient au
courant des deux autres morceaux qu'ils
apprennent celle là surtout que martha
elle pas écoute si elle t'a dit qu'il
lirait rien à personne ne lira rien j'en
mettrais ma main au feu à temps si
sérieux vous dit pas un mot de ce qui
s'est passé chez l'armurier je suis
désolé
il faut que personne ne soit au courant
non sérieux et si on nous accuse d'être
complice moi je veux qu'on dise de rien
ça ne va vous accusez il faut en parler
à personne
je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit un peu
plus solidaire et que s'il ya des
emmerdes on peut lui filer un coup de
main on peut pas laisser tout seul quand
même vous pouvez pas savoir ce que c'est
je suis tout seul j'ai l'impression
d'être dans un trou noir et personnes
demain
[Musique]
la pauvre c'est affreux c'est bien t'en
fais pas moi je dirai rien à personne je
te le jure qu on est avec toi mais on a
besoin de votre aide
sylvia eu un problème avec richard le
mec de la boutique nazis elle a été
obligée de le tuer il faut que vous
soyez avec nous pour nous aider à
l'enterrer cette nuit à temps mais quand
on y va tous y ont fait une pub d'enfer
un terrien mort ça doit être méga fan je
vois pas pourquoi on irait tout ce que
vos copains y aille mais nous on reste
là faut que la classe soit solidaire
c'est le problème de sylvia mais ça
aurait pu arriver à n'importe qui
d'autre à ta nana par exemple moi j'ai
pas le droit de sortir tard le soir
patricia tu veux que je cap devant tout
le monde
bon d'accord je ferai une mûre on n'a
qu'à voter ok lever la main ceux qui
sont pour 10 maintenant ceux qui sont
contre ça fait 10 égalité puisque c'est
comme ça hors au vote
ceux qui sont pour lever la main
[Musique]
il a personne d'autre pas encore écoute
ravie je pige pas tu nous dis pas parler
du mort et toi tu craches le morceau
aussi sec
tu voulais que je fasse quoi que je
laisse toute la classe pensais qu'on
avait déjà enterré de cadavre et risquer
quelqu'un et tous dénoncés aux flics ah
c'est ça il vaut mieux qu'ils sachent
qu'on en a flingué trop lieu de deux
bien sûr parce que si ce soir ils
viennent nous aider à l'intéressant fait
les complices
plus personne ne nous dénoncera
[Musique]
elle est vachement rouges s'étaient mal
moment épisode bien la première chose
qu'il faut que vous sachiez c'est que
rien de tout ça ne doit sortir d'ici
et si un problème on se retrouve ici
dans le bar du père de ravi à cette
heure ci et si on nous pose des
questions bah tu dis rien ouais mais
s'ils nous arrêtent et qui nous
interroge excusez moi mais il n'y a
aucune raison qu'ils se doute de quoi
que ce soit tant qu'on retrouve pas les
cadavres ce ne sont que des personnes
disparues et s'ils décident de creuser à
temps ja 17 hectares de parc
ils trouveront jamais rien même si on
enterre un éléphant donc c'est décidé ce
sera notre point de rencontre bon allez
il faut aller se coucher parce que
demain on se lève tôt par contre si vous
pouvez ranger les chaises
code naf ronito écoute dit à moi mais je
viens justement entretenir avec les
pousses de pablo domingo du sel
professeurs et tiens toi bien il paraît
qu'il avait une liaison avec la
professeur qui a disparu sa femme dit
qu'elle est convaincue qu ils se sont
tirés aux caraïbes
j'en sais rien j'en sais rien c'est une
affaire classée
mais non mais non mais non mais non
commença à faire classer commença à
faire classer pour pas de bouger le cul
tu es capable d'inventer n'importe quoi
toi barre face d'abord dans la boutique
nazis rue delpech pourquoi on a une
nouvelle disparition
tu parles d'une coïncidence une
coïncidence ou qui sait un ménage à
trois tu pense qu'à ça d'accord tout à
l'heure je passe au commissariat mais
plus tard
le corps de la femme est un temple mes
baisers qui prodigue de douces caresses
faut ouvrir les pores ils vont te
préparer au plaisir la femme est la
déesse de l'amour
et la première fois la plus importante
de toutes
indique moi le chemin qui conduit à des
zones érogènes procès rth et je suis pas
vierge quoi
je suis pas vierge ça fait rien ça ne te
fait rien non on est adulte n'en jetez
plus qu'avant si je tenais pas dit c'est
parce que j'avais peur que tu comprennes
pas ces choses là
ce que je peux être bête qu'est ce qui
se passe
pourquoi tu m'a rien dit tu viens de
dire que ce n'était pas important
merde ces choses là on les dit c'est
sage et qu'elle met dans le journal
c'était qui on s'en fout non non non non
on s'en fout pas parce que je suis sûr
tu as pris ton pied avec lui bah oui ça
me paraît normal
si j'avais pas trouvé ça bien je
l'aurais pas fait et le corps de la
femme qui est un temple c'était du bidon
alors non mais c'est pas pour autant
qu'il faut que tu niques tous les mecs
qui passent tu es un vrai talibans le
moi qui croyais intelligent tu me déçois
et toi tu l'as fait c'est quoi ce n'est
pas de ça qu'on parle ce que tu es
mathieu toi et toi t'es qu'une [ __ ]
redit moi ça je te fais aval et au
téléphone oui martin c'est moi sylvia
remis ça encore une fois ouais elle a
tué une caissière ce matin olala appelle
tout le monde et donne rendez-vous
ouais
bon
on y va mauvais chiffres désolé je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé c'est parce
qu'elle m'a regardé d'un drôle des
écoutes sylvia tais toi tais toi parce
que si tu continues à parler toi ou moi
on va finir comme elle est d'ailleurs ça
résoudrait le problème est là
patricia quelque chose à nous dire
j'ai vu un policier il fait une enquête
il a pas l'air de grand chose mais mais
c'est seulement un flic je crois qu'il
faut pas qu'on s'inquiète pour sa non si
ça devient trop gênant on peut se
rencontrer ici tous les soirs on
s'appelle les uns les autres et comme ça
tout le monde sera au courant oui
joachim ben moi j'ai d'autres trucs à
vous dire je trouve que ce qu'on fait
est mal très mal
la caissière je m'en fiche parce que je
la connaissais pas et que ça m'est égal
mais cette espèce de nazis c'était un
imbécile et les profs aussi sincèrement
ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est que ici
où on est tous musulmans où on est tous
chrétiens parce que et je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est toujours sylvie 1 qu'elle
doit tuer les gens qui si je vous dis
parce que moi aussi ça me dirait bien je
veux collaborer
je vais vous aider tous aillent et
j'aimerais il y a deux racaille qui me
font chier j'aimerais leur faire la peau
c'est joachim prison nous on a un voisin
qui m'ont pipelette et à chaque fois que
mes parents sans voir la fin de la
semaine le lundi l' cafta mais vu que
l'usm on est resté là tout le week-end
on pourrait lui faire la même chose à
lui
attendez voir je crois qu'on devrait
mettre de côté nos petites histoires
privées et dégommer ce [ __ ] de prof
de maths il va encore nous recaler sur
le fait ça c'est excellent et il ya un
sim directeur pour les mélodies acteur
il est très con mais n'est pas
antipathique
ouais mais il me fait chier exactement
ouais elle te fait chier parce que tu es
bien rouler non c'est vrai qu'on bon ok
on se calme s'il vous plaît on va faire
les choses bien
on va voter 1 alors ceux qui sont pour
descendre le directeur lever la main des
3 4 5
ok et ceux qui veulent descendre le prof
de maths 7 8 9 10 et ceux qui veulent
tuer le voisin de luz me
d'accord le vote a eu lieu faut que ce
soit très clair que personne ne peut
descendre quiconque aura pas été lu par
la majorité
je crois qu'on pourrait créer des
comités pour bien faire les choses j'ai
la liste de tous les gens de la classe
fait la voix ok les cinq premiers de la
liste iront chercher les cadavres
les quatre suivants efface pour les
empreintes les quatre suivants plan kron
les cadavres et les quatre derniers
feront le plus amusant liquider les gens
je suis pas du tout d'accord mais on
changera chaque semaine inquiète bon
tout a été dit la séance est levée et on
commence par ce [ __ ] de prof de
maths je ne ferai pas de concessions
cette année vous échouerez au contrôle
continu avec un 4 99 en fin d'année
comme personne ne se donne la peine je
ne lèverai le petit doigt pour aucun
d'entre vous et si par la faute de votre
échec en maths
vous ne pouvez entrer à l'université ce
sera votre problème pas le mien à nam
n'est surtout pas vos mamans pour me
supplier pour que je fasse passer leurs
petits chéris non
la vie est une jungle avec moi vous
apprendrez à y vivre
[Musique]
bonjour ça se passe bien en classe
ouais bon eh bien j'en ai une qui
commence à plus tard voire voit entrer
vous n'avez pas cours
ben en fait
on voulait vous demander si on pouvait
rendre le devoir de maths plus tard que
prévu
je vous ai donné une date ouais mais les
examens vont bientôt commencer vous
savez et lundi on doit rendre un devoir
d'histoire alors 1 messieurs ne me fait
pas douter de votre capacité de
compréhension
ben moi je trouve ça dommage parce que
c'est pour vous qu'on fait vous vous
souvenez quand on a eu une évaluation
vous nous avez donné un devoir de 30
pages 30 pages en une semaine
bien entendu oui et quand vous m'avez
coller un 4,5 et j'ai dû redoubler et
moi vous m'avez mis passable et ben ça
c'est pas sympa en plus bosseurs commis
les bains peut-être qu il le fait par
obligation il s'appelait jean par
plaisir avec des gens comme vous c'est
certain
vous savez si la fois vous avez ça
qu'est la moitié de la classe parce
qu'on avait rendu un deux voire trop
tard vous étiez comporter d'une autre
manière
peut-être que là on n'aurait pas été
forcé de venir vous voir aujourd'hui tu
as entièrement raison
mais l'ennui c'est que vous êtes un sale
con c'est pour ça qu'on est venu à sale
con et un vrai [ __ ] de première vous
êtes un fils de [ __ ]
considérez vous recalé pour toute votre
vie
allez jean kiffer la douleur
[Musique]
[ __ ] bien viser le prochain c'est moi
s'il est vrai avec la pâte
sinon vous allez encore merdé hors de
question si ce sera notre comité et bien
on fera une réunion moi je veux changer
comique et si tous voila je veux faire
une proposition ce soir pour voir si
sauf que tu es ce que j'ai envie tu es
écoute la hutte faut que ce soit
approuvée par la majorité vous pétez un
cap tout ce mec t'as vu la tronche du
prof de maths c'était trop drôle
maintenant ce connard il pourra plus
nous recaler et le tuer ça vous a pas
déposé
non à vrai dire non j'ai déjà vu tuer
des animaux dans le village et serra qui
coûte
[Musique]
et où il va suis là c'est rien c'est mon
frangin
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous foutez là ça lucky
oui ça le rendrait alors tu te dégoûter
fiancé ou tu continues à te restait
qu'une voix le porno amer qui s'y colle
elle a plus d'expérience malgré top
qu'est ce que tu fous là pour coter pas
en classe on n'a pas cours là je veux
dire à maman voir si c'est vrai elle est
basse la voiture là c'est qu'on a
beaucoup de poids vous partez en voyage
ou quoi mais qu'est-ce que vous
fabriquez
en fait il y à tous nos sacs à dos
[Musique]
non
qu'est ce que t'as coutu venez on
remonte louise je peux tout expliqué
julien m'expliquer parce que je vais
tout raconter à maman à maman bien un
lion sur le coffre
telle la chanson puis son camp lui
ouvrir le coffre sinon c'était la
connerie du siècle il a black aces elle
est dégueulasse venait offrir cette
génération sont vraiment craindre
j'ai pas voulu vous en parler avant
qu'on soit tous ensemble on s'était
promis de ne tuer personne avant de
s'être tous mis d'accord mais sylvia
enfreint la règle ce week end elle a tué
un gars qui chantait dans un orchestre
je voulais pas le faire mais c'est
dimanche j'ai eu le mariage de ma tarte
il est aux banques ils chantaient des
espèces de chansons horrible comme des
bombes le retrait de la tête ça me
faisait mal
je meurs de plaisir je meurs de plaisir
tout le monde trouvait ça très bien
croyez-le macarena j'ai cru devenir fou
rien j'ai attendu qu'il sorte du banc
que je les subis jusqu'aux toilettes je
n'ai tu a cappella tarte
[Musique]
je vais traîner jusqu'aux parkings
gelais mais dans le coffre de la voiture
de mes parents j'ai appelé ravis et
nouria tu sais je crois que tu est
gravement malade
j'suis pas mal à tétouan qu'il est dans
quelle case est un peu de câbles je
comprends parfaitement qu'il l'ait
zigouiller parce que la macarena bah
c'est pas mon truc mais enfin elle a
désobéi quand même c'est pas pourquoi
elle aime pas la macarena pour une fête
c'est bien pardon moi je trouve ça
chouette c'est une chanson comme une
autre y a pas de quoi être intégriste
non pas du tout moi je trouve ça plus
que suffisant comme horizon pour rompre
le pacte mais il faut voir si cette nana
peu flinguer n'importe qui quand elle en
a une petite envie dans ce cas moi je
peux le faire aussi
et vous le pouvez franchement 1 8 me un
droit de flinguer un salban leurs deux
voisins qui lui pourrit la vie
joachim peu flinguer leader accueille 1
et nous aussi les mecs on a droit de
flinguer des salles batère qui nous
pourrissent la vie continuellement faut
l'faire bordel
c'est vrai quoi faut le faire mais vous
êtes donnent tous je refuse on va tous
se faire coffrer non il nous reste un
peu de temps pour quoi pour qui nous
arrête pour que la police commence à
enquêter sur une disparition il faut
qu'il se passe au moins 24 heures j'ai
vu ça dans un film à et moi aussi je les
fais c'est à dire qu on a 24 heures pour
tuer tous les gens qu'on veut si on fait
ça bien on zigouille tout ce qu'ils nous
emmerdent ni vu ni connu
bah ouais c'est pas cool moi je sais
comment ça tu en sais rien c'est très
risqué et mec
personne n'a dit qu'il fallait que tu te
mettes faut juste être là à 2 heures du
matin j'en sais rien arrête de dire ça
on est tous ensemble survivants nous
sert elle ce qui est clair c'est que
celui qui tue quelqu'un devra se
débarrasser du mort et ensuite enlevé
toutes les traces on sait comment faire
les films policiers ne parle que de ça
ce qu'on peut faire c'est voter bon
d'accord
ceux qui sont en faveur de tuer tout ce
qu'ils veulent en 24 heures lever la
main et maintenant ceux qui sont contre
bon bah tout est dit la séance est levée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
pour commencer
j'avais du sel c'est que maintenant tu
peux dire à différentes j'en ai assez de
vous entendre entre experts le soir avec
mon beau temps et tous ces gens aigris
qui traîne la nuit normale
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marylène m
à
mettez de la ville
non que celui-ci de la barre des
ça a été super
[Musique]
arrivée mais ave
il m
paris
[Musique]
t'aurais la vega la police n'a aucune
idée ces individus et on file bien sûr
les hypothèses vont bon train parmi les
possibles nous avons le psychotique
échappé d'un asile psychiatrique
oui l'amour tu sais qu'on est en train
de se ridiculiser devant toute l'espagne
non c'est pas si grave
faut pas exagérer pour rabaisser jamais
tu la regardes la télévision qu'est ce
que tu fous pour essayer de trouver les
tueurs moi mais tu le sais déjà
non non non la seule chose que je sais
c'est que tu prends le rien du tout tél
au lycée oui j'ai interrogé les
professeurs et les élèves non attends
t'es pas sérieux mais il faut que tu
interroges des élèves juanito tape à
passer une seconde qu'ils auraient
peut-être pu voir quelque chose dont on
s'emmerde
c'est bon c'est bon d'accord je crois un
peu sinon la direction va nous inquiète
à l'idée
tu as terminé
oui bah va dans le bureau du directeur
ils t'attendent déjà ça vous concerne
tous
la police est en train d'interroger tous
les élèves du lycée alors au fur et à
mesure que vous terminerez vos épreuves
il faudra aller dans le bureau du
directeur
merci beaucoup très bien et est ce que
tu as vu quelque chose de douteux
récemment non pourquoi tu es en
survêtement tu as cours de gym
aujourd'hui non mais je le porte parfois
je fais du sport tu fais quel sport
football
ah ouais moi je suis très bon en
football peut-être qu'on jouera une
partie je vois bon poursuivre tu
connaissais certaines des personnes
disparues non mais j'en avais type
donner des cours alors à oui pardon
pardon
ouais et tu connais quelqu'un qui
pourrait savoir quelque chose sûre
comment sur wii enfin si on sait des
trucs
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien si on
sait et qu'on ne dit rien on peut passer
un bon bout de temps en prison
et si toi tu connais quelqu'un qui sait
et que tu ne dis rien toi aussi tu peux
y passer quelques années et ne sortir
que quand tu auras les cheveux blancs
alors tu as quelque chose à me dire
eh bien je enfin nous cite à montaut on
n'a jamais dit frappé avant d'entrer où
tu vas si j'y vais pas maintenant je
vais rater des jeunes y déceler entre
ferme
assieds toi nom et prénom et sylvie un
guéridon restée là le numéro 7
ben voyons sylvia est ce que tu
connaissais certaines personnes parmi
celles qui ont disparu des autres
épreuves non je voulais dire 'est-ce que
tu avais une relation personnelle avec
l'un d'entre eux non et est-ce que
récemment tu as vu quelque chose qui
était sembler bizarre non quelqu'un de
louche qui rôde et par ici oui oui vous
ça va ouais si personne ne craque tout
ira bien
ravi on a un problème rodrigo un
alistair dans son armoire
il dit qu'il a oublié tout le monde le
sait mais personne ne sait quoi faire et
on a décidé que tu allais les parler ce
soir ah non non moi je dis plus rien
ravi
[Musique]
et m qu'est-ce qui se passe c'était un
vrai con rodrigo c'est pas la peine de
me dire ça c'est que j'ai oublié avec
l'émotion et tout ça pété un câble c'est
tout tu as une idée de ce qu'il faut
faire il ya des flics absolument partout
et elle inquiète inquiète un jules dans
réfléchir j'ai trouvé la solution
est ce que tu as vu delicatessen manger
c'est vraiment génial
là ça se passe pendant la troisième
guerre mondiale c'est l'histoire d'un
beau chic qui font du chien et mais
attends tu veux que les gens mangent de
la chair humaine
je tiens à manger de la firme de fruges
toi non bah voilà
personne n'a jamais mangé le père de
pablito ayouch rit et on peut pas faire
ça pourquoi c'est pas une bonne idée
c'est tu n'as pas vu pablo coupé de
l'avion une brève et sans une soirée
tous ces joints tu fumes ça déglingue
vraiment la tête peut-être mais comme ça
mais qu'on règle au moins le problème
tandis que si on n'arrive pas à se
débarrasser du corps on est foutu faites
attention
posez le sur la table
le vendeur de journaux maintenant
non mais là vous n'êtes pas cool excuse
moi si j'avais su que tu l'aimé bien
j'aurai non c'est pas que je l'aimé bien
belle au kiosque va rester fermé dix
jours j'ai pas eu mon hebdo cette
semaine ben si tout se passe bien on en
prendra un abonnement voilà sûr j'ai
déjà tout dit à rodrigues on peut
prendre certains morceaux et les faire
passer pour de l'autruche ou pour une
viande similaires et les abats on peut
les mélanger avec les foies de volaille
électrique de porc et d'agneau
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que je ne suis
pas responsable de tout ce qu'ils
travaillent que c'est un corps humain
c'est-à-dire les pieds les mains et la
tête
t'inquiète si les pelles a enfin parlé
entre les bombers va commencer 6
[Musique]
m
bon alors on a cinq paille hockey et ça
n'a aucune importance si on a une main
ou un pied ou quoi que ce soit une des
pailles qui est plus petit et celui qui
les tient la danse qu il se farcit les
bras ou la tête
on y va procès c'est à ton tour mais non
toi plutôt kravis non plutôt serge sûrs
pourquoi non toile ou semi vous allez
quand même pas vous dégonfler les mecs
ok les gars on le fait tous ensemble
d'accords est un
les mecs les mecs les mecs très vite
échanger avec moi voile est une [ __ ] 1 2
et 3 ont surtout tu fais ça sans laisser
de traces mais qu'il fallut
[Musique]
certes mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
et toi tu fais quoi moi je suis resté
ici c'est tout vous faites quoi les mecs
mais dieu merci tout cas maman tu vas
voir tu vas voir
bonjour bonjour vous deviez pas revenir
lundi
ouais mais ton père il ya un peu malade
alors on a dû revenir avant ce qui fait
quoi j'allais sortir jouer au foot avec
les autres avec quoi avec le vieux qu'à
moitié garée de l'autre
franchement maman tu deviens pénible j'y
vais c'est de la viande d'autruche
la mère de famille tout m'a dit qu'avec
une petite sauce c'était très bon
d'ailleurs ça s'est très bien vendu
toute la lune en acheter oui c'est très
bon jean prat vrai pour le bar on fera
des tapas qu'elle mange rien aujourd'hui
j'ai pas faim je vois que ça tu n'as
rien avaler ça ne fait pas envie
ben may prend ou moins mouche et tu
verras si c'est bon tu sais moi l'avions
d'autruche ces derniers temps tu es
bizarre shearing pourquoi tu ne veux pas
essayer
[Musique]
c'est pour moi bah pourquoi tu es si
près c'est ouais c crosser à je te
remercie ma mère voulait que je mange de
la viande d'autruche qu'elle vient
d'acheter
heureusement que tu as appelé la mienne
aussi l acheter de la viande d'autruche
mais moi personne ne m'a appelé j'ai été
obligé de la bouffe et j'ai été vomir
cinq fois art à pas de chance mon vieux
ouais t'as fait ce qu'il fallait
ouais ouais je les ai mis à la poubelle
ce matin moi j'ai pas réussi à m'en
débarrasser
mes parents m'ont dit de m'occuper de ma
petite soeur pour la calmer devine ce
que je lui ai donné
[Musique]
oui tu as des nouvelles ronito justement
en train d'interroger des témoins de la
faire en fait ça fait plusieurs jours
que j'arrête pas d'interroger des gens
d'un point de la villette
il va falloir que d'une augmentation
vieux pris sur le fait
si je ne t'ai pas encore viré de la
police c'est parce que ta soeur me
foutrait dehors tu sais rhône hitoshi
toujours en train d'essayer de te
couvrir mais comme t'as aucun résultat
on va être la risée de la profession je
vais être obligé de virer prend une
assiette théâtre c'est au moins tu avais
une piste qu'on sache où on en est rien
personne ne sait rien personne n'a rien
vu c'est comme comme s'ils s'étaient
évaporés témoin tiens tant de gens ne
peuvent pas disparaître de cette manière
il doit mettre quelque part
juanito nul on sait bon qu'est ce que
c'est ouais c'est délicieux cette p eng
et il est enfin profitant parce que
c'est pas tous les jours que tu vas
manger ça fait passer les épreuves vous
avez 50 minutes et ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est très facile à entreprendre à
feuilles d'examen
il faut que tu fasses attention parce
que si tu a mauvaise réputation
les garçons ne te respecte pa oui mais
c'est pas de ma faute je suis jeune je
suis chaud à les battants non mais je te
jure
bon c'était la dernière
alors tu n'as toujours pas acheté bah là
on est bien je suis désolé mais je suis
à cours d'idées monsieur alors on savait
un peu plus et bien non et se moquer de
professeurs se soit enfuie ensemble etc
la caissière du supermarché et fait
pareil avec les nazis
personne ne semble avoir de mobile clair
qu'est ce que t'en as fait j'espère que
tu l'a pas mise au frigo bien je crois
qu'on va abandonner
bon si on peut faire quelque chose pour
vous contactez nous moi et merci au
revoir
arrête tes conneries et dis moi ce que
tu a foutu non tu rigoles il est dû il a
[Musique]
mis la tête dans le ballon john ce match
ni la tête du mordant pas le nom qu'il
va nous testons moi aussi j'ai fait du
sport
à plat ventre tout le monde je suis
désolé
taza geste
rires il n'y a rien je peux pas le
croire
il est forcément ici on a ouvert tous
les ballons du lycée de tous les types
et on n'a rien trouvé monsieur ben ali
peut passer très apeuré voyons allait
continuer à chercher
oui écoute moi ni taux je viens
d'appeler le bureau il me racontait son
histoire
si j'ai bien compris tu veux coffret
vingt gamins et les mettre en taule
c'est bien ça exactement c'est n'importe
quoi
tu sais qu'on ne peut pas coffret
quelqu'un sur un simple soupçon et
encore moins quand les suspects sont
mineurs et tout ça parce que soi disant
tu aurais vu une tête de mort à
l'intérieur d'un ballon de football
mais t'as fumé la moquette ou quoi
juanito bon à bien si tu préfères on les
laisse courir et continueront à tuer
tout le monde
mais tu n'as aucune preuve non de dieu
ben justement c'est la seule que j'ai et
puis j'ai d'autres motivations
quelle motivation d'autres motivations
je peux rien dire maintenant mais j'ai
une sorte d'intuition retrouve moi un
seul cadavre ni toi seul cadavre et tu
pourras jeter qui tu voudras en taule
mais tu peux pas incarcérer tout en lice
et cet idiot
pour mon
on
merde mais on est cuit
non pas si on réagit vite
allez on y va au boulot
[Musique]
la prochaine fois que ce matin il me
faut que cette merde toi j défonce la
cloison nasale à ce pauvre con je te le
dis c'est vrai quoi et ils en profitent
[ __ ] ils exploitent à mort quoi et tu
sais comme ils savent que tu es obligé
d'aller de fournir en cam tu te
retrouves là bas elle te sautent dessus
tu te retrouves sur des couilles de
toute façon c'est une ville pourrie
c'est au moment où on était dans une
grande ville tu sais comme barcelone
madrid le bronx war le bronx ça me
rangerai comme blade et là ce soir tu
vois j'ai envie de cogner tout ce qui
bouge si jamais je me retrouve nez à nez
avec l'autre connard ben j'y mets mon
point là où je pense
tu vois [ __ ] de sa mère [ __ ] de
merde
[Musique]
et
toi fier bien fait pour google
ça finira jamais les mecs allez on y
retourne excusez-moi de vous avoir
réveillé mais comme vous nous avez dit
vous avertir s'il y avait un nouveau
décès oui mais pas si c'était un
accident
le camionneur a entendu du bruit près du
parc de kabardino juste avant de
percuter la victime
oh la vache il a vraiment aplatit
bon
je vais vous avoir à rendre le salon
bonjour si on n'y est pas il se casse
17 18
mais glissant tous
d'après la liste il en manque un nom
c'est celui qu rodrigo les oubliés chez
abc
mais dans ces cas-là il yal total aux
appels ravier noria pour leur dire
d'accord
le comité de remplissage des fautes
reste là nous on s'en va
[Musique]
vie qu'est ce que tu vas faire quand ce
sera fini je vais me reposer
oui mais et tout redeviendra comme avant
si tu me demande si je vais recommencer
à te faire chier pas de souci la réponse
est non
c'était pas ça mais pourquoi t'as pas
mis sur bois de vibreur est ce que j'ai
oublié et et qui hélas bien et
plutôt autres la petite alors
allez
foutez le camp d'ici je vous fais une
volée plan cul
[Musique]
signaté [ __ ] et des gens qui y
prenez-vous en retard
[Musique]
gardiens ces bons candidats
allez-vous plus vite que ça t'es sur qui
regardent pas dans la déchetterie la
voyageuse
pour pelles et des gâteaux vachon
en tout cas merci pour tous chinois
commencent à sortir en retraite normale
tout le monde doit pas forcément être au
courant de nos petits secrets
les mains en l'air on bouge plus vous
vous croyez très futés l'espoir pourtant
je viens de vous prendre en flagrant
délit ça va partait pour vos gueules
qu'est ce que vous regardez vos autres
retourner tout de suite bosser ça c'est
la sphère de la police
comme ça vous pensiez que j'avais le
revo saladana coup vous vous disiez que
j'étais pas un bon flic c'est ça hein
c'est la terre rouge oui c'est la terre
qui m'a mise sur votre piste
maintenant je sais nous enterrer les
cadavres à quelques pauvres quelques
ouais bien sûr fait les innocents mais
bonne nuit
c'est sa venue et demain j'irai dans le
parc avec les excavatrices les chiens et
aux tatouages
sachez que je suis à deux doigts de
retrouver les cadavres
[Applaudissements]
à
j'ai la fille il ya plus de preuves
contre eux n'auront finalement tout est
bien qui finit bien
enfin presque non guillermo j'ai pris ma
décision
qu'est ce que tu racontes ce sont eux je
le sais ce sont eux qui ont fait le coup
merouani d'automne histoire d' élèves
d'un lycée qui ce qui tue dix neuf
personnes sont laissées de piste ni
trace ni cadavre ni rien du tour c'est
franchement incroyable non ah oui mais
comment tu expliques le coût du ballon 1
et le fait qu'ils étaient avec des
pelles à 5 heures du matin ronito ça
fait trois mois que tu mets le parc de
cabaret nos sens dessus dessous et
pourtant tu n'as rien retrouvé et au
fait pourquoi tu trouves pas parce que
je veux pas de représailles voilà si je
reste ici ces [ __ ] pas bien avant de
faire la peau c'est pour ça que j'ai
demandé un congé
maintenant je suis dans le train pour
hendaye et je vais en prendre un autre
pour paris je vais habiter chez ma
cousine à paris pendant plusieurs mois
j'ai pas pourquoi mais je crois qu à
force je deviens parano
bon comme tu véronique toi tu sais que
tu peux revenir à tout moment au pays
bien sûr je reviendrai un jour ne serait
ce que pour coffrer tout ces bâtards
c'est bien ça d'un policier dans l'amour
ni toi prends soin de toi oui au revoir
[Musique]
pour le tir fin de l'histoire